welcome to
of ourMitgliederversammlung today,
That I am talking about right now.
it's taking place behind me right now,
here from Duisburg.
1.
CircleMitgliederversammlung,
as the name suggests,
gathers all members,
who have just at the time ponder from us,
to make important decision.
for example,
we just had a choice
for the ordinary conducted to country
religious conference
or we also had applications
adopted or presented.
exactly why
I am also speaking to you right now,
because it was more important to me to say,
what we actually say here.
so it was,
for example,
the green youth,
our political spokeswoman iklam kapschi
and Me especially concerned and stronger against right
or perhaps more active again in these times
against the right.
because our group here in the
Wheel in Duisburg
already does some
actually and brings with its requests and ideas
a lot of progress.
but we believe,
that we just
now perhaps also need an overarching AG,
for example,
which are quite also
should function beyond the party or also
can work,
for example,
with allies who oppose grannies on the right
or also with other parties or other initiatives,
perhaps also with students and groups,
that we are trying to forge alliances there,
to also again
just in this basically super choice yes
to set ourselves up accordingly.
because we are all convinced of this,
that just the mobilization
From and into right-wing has increased
and we therefore together
as a and democrat our
Have to raise voice.
and there we want green
definitely.
1st part of be.